Jade helm 15 while the military set is
it's just training soldiers for the
realities of war critics say the Army is
preparing for modern day martial law
and said that I said that martial law
was cutting the summer and that Obama
was going to invade Texas no it's
incremental they're not going to take
over the summer probably we never say
completely
governor Abbott of Texas said he and
Texas respect the military troops but
make no mistake he wants his people to
keep an eye on what they are doing you
know I understand the concern that's
been raised by a lot of citizens about
Jade helm this question I'm getting a
lot
Texas there's no Texas take over the
United States government already control
come hug